[Music]  [Music]  [Music]  ohayo gozaimasu hi try not to move right  now we are on our way to Ensenada Mexico  on a cruise and  you know this is our first time going on  a cruise with each other with anyone  period and it's really nice the first  thing I get to see if this big deep blue  sea and a beautiful clear sky with some  puffs of clouds and it's really nice and  refreshing I like going on trips with  you because we rarely get quality time  with each other back in LA because we're  so busy with our work and I think it's  nice that we get to take a break  spend time with each other even though  you have to record it work it's still I  get to see you more than by someone  [Music]  you